good morning John less than a year ago I
was in Haiti learning about the people
there and their problems and their
dreams and their hopes and their
frustration I was there with water.org
because they wanted to share their work
with me so that I could share it to the
rest of the world through my eyes or
least through my camera what I found in
hitting was astounding to me not that
these people are living in basically
what we consider the hygiene of the
Middle Ages but that they are you know
the important ways exactly like me and
my friends in my family they care about
each other they like to eat sweet things
they like to dance and have fun and
laugh and very strong and complicated
communities and they want a better life
for themselves and for their children
spend some time there in a village
called savant epoch where the citizens
of that village had asked one of water
God works partner organizations to come
in and help them build wealth their
water source at the times about a
20-minute walk away from the village and
it was a muddy hole in the ground really
so when I came back I told you all about
these people and I asked you to donate
money to water.org we all work together
and we gave those people something that
they needed now boats and gluto and ulna
jean-baptiste and ISA heat in Jena they
now have a little
[Music]
thanks to nerdfighteria and water.org
those people have more than just a well
they have a community-owned asset that
people pay a fair price to use and that
money goes into maintaining that asset
so that 20 30 50 years from now those
people still have a source of clean
water they've built something with the
communities invested in has control over
and cooperatively maintains and now
because of this resource they have more
time to grow their economy to educate
themselves and their children because
they could spend less time going to get
water and last time being sick when I
was there Jena one of the youngest
members of the well committee spoke out
and said that this has to be a better
way she was just frustrated and now she
has that better way she also remembered
me which was nice and she was asking
where I was Christmas please consider
donating to water.org they do it well
and they do it right and of course got a
project for awesome calm and vote for
water org so that they can get a piece
of the project for awesome fun thank you
to everyone who gave from the depth of
my heart this is just like one of the
most amazing and just touching and
inspiring things that I've ever been a
part of so thank you all so much for
that John
I'll see you on the livestream oh hey in
screen there's a video not if you click
here you can watch the explains what the
project your awesome is how it works and
how you can participate